I want you to pause the video and read
this problem well let's go through this
example together it says that a quiz has
ten questions and is worth 50 points at
this point do not assume that each
question will be worth five points we
don't know about the weight edge of each
question yet the next line is very
important it says that the test consists
of two types of questions multiple
choice questions and fill-in-the-blank
questions
have you been told how many of each type
we have in the quiz nope but we've been
given how many marks you get for each
question we answer correctly if the
answer an empty queue question correctly
we get three points and if we answer a
fill in the blank question correctly we
get eight points and what is that we've
been asked for the number of empty cues
on the test select the number of empty
cues on the test pm and a number of fi
beads on the test bf we've been asked to
find a value of M let's break the
information down what does the first
line tell us the quiz has ten questions
in total what will that mean in terms of
m and F come on you should be able to
answer this it tells us that M plus s
will equal 10 some of em PQ's and fi
base will equal 10 because these are the
only two types of questions in the quiz
next it tells us that the maximum points
you can score in the quiz it's 50 and
the weight age of each MP q is 3 points
and that of each fib question is 8
points can you frame an equation with
this data try it
the maximum mask you can get with MP Q's
is 3 times M and the maximum marks you
can get with fib s is 8 times F so the
equation which explains this part is 3 M
plus 8 F equals 50 these are the two
linear equations we formed based on the
data provided in the question M plus f
equals 10 and 3 M plus 8 F equals 50 how
do we solve this
none of the coefficients are the same
which means we cannot add or subtract
directly we need to modify the equations
to make the coefficients of one of the
variables same as we think asked for the
value of M let's make the coefficients
of s same so we multiply the first
equation with 8 to get there let's just
be the third equation to eliminate F we
can subtract the second equation from
the third one 8 M minus 3 M plus 8 F
minus 8 F equals 80 minus 50 we get 5m s
30 and that gives us the value of M at 6
there are six empty queues on the test
and if the rustics MCQs the remaining
four will be fib questions the only
thing you need to use with word problem
is breaking it down word by word
[Music]